bueno bardem es fundamentalmente está en
un esfuerzo de restaurar las relaciones
con los aliados altamente deterioradas
por la administración de trump y
y relanzar el multilateralismo como una
manera de poder generar una gobernanza
global que restaure el liderazgo de eeuu
a nivel internacional y en ese sentido
la cumbre de los países más
industrializados del c7 es fundamental
porque es cómo replantear el
multilateralismo de amigos que requiere
estados unidos para relanzar su
presencia protagónica en el sistema
internacional ahora aprovechando la
visita a bruselas de bailén para
reunirse con la otan el próximo 14 de
junio en la unión europea también tendrá
reunión con el mandatario estadounidense
cuál es la importancia de la
restauración de estas relaciones con el
bloque que en la política exterior
estaban deterioradas por el aire a trump
pero fundamentalmente la importancia
está relacionada con que el mundo ha
vivido una transformación muy
significativa se han profundizando una
serie de tendencias que minan la
importancia del multilateralismo que
afectan la gobernanza global y desde
luego que impactan también en el proceso
de globalización con toda una serie de
planteamientos en torno a las carreras
suministros y en ese sentido está muy
claro que la aspiración de la
administración bailén es reconstituir
las alianzas y los vínculos positivos
con aquellas aquellos países que en
especial representan distintas formas de
democracia occidental entonces
evidentemente también la visita y la
participación imágenes en el g7
y participación la reunión de la otan
tienen implicaciones muy claras en
relación con lo que la administración de
eeuu considera las principales amenazas
a su seguridad y son que son china y
rúsia por lo tanto la consecuencia
digamos la frutilla del postre del
proceso de este viaje es la reunión con
putin y un intento de estabilizar las
relaciones entre eeuu bloque occidental
en general y rusia en un marco en donde
rusia y china- se acercan cada vez más y
constituyen a su vez una alternativa en
el sistema internacional dress
rápidamente tocaba un punto muy
importante y es la reunión que se espera
entonces del presidente by the end con
su homólogo ruso vladimir putin que
puede salir de esta reunión
bueno ninguno de los dos presidentes
tienen grandes expectativas en términos
de los avances de esta reunión los dos
lo han expresado muy claramente pero lo
más importante es que la reunión cede en
primer lugar porque restablece un canal
de comunicación directo entre los dos
presidentes y muy deterioradas en este
momento y en segundo lugar permite
analizar una agenda en donde hay una
serie de temas que son de carácter común
que interesan a los dos países que más
que nada se relacionan con la agenda
global tanto lo que tiene que ver con la
lucha contra la pandemia como los temas
de cambio climático los temas de lucha
contra el terrorismo y la estabilización
estratégica esto es muy importante
considerando que ambos han
firmado la continuidad del tratado start
a necesitar 3 entonces estos temas son
los temas más preponderantes yo diría
dentro de la agenda de la reunión y hay
otros temas muy puntuales que tienen que
ver con las tensiones y conflictos
regionales que se dan entre ambos países